hi everyone
welcome to our talk today we're going to
be talking about
building data applications powered by
looker
my name is mike shu i'm an architect at
google
i help our customers design architect
and build their
applications using the looker platform
and today i'm also joined by my friend
and colleague
nick hey everyone i'm nick fogler i'm
the founder
and ceo of four mile analytics and uh
we're a strategic local partner really
specializing in the kind of custom data
experiences built on top of
uh the looker platform features we'll be
talking about today
so for our agenda and our talk today
we're going to be covering looking at
the platform
uh all the different facets of uh
lookers platform to build your
application
and also we're going to be looking at a
case study of building an application
using one of these facets which is the
api for a global
fortune 100 retailer
so look at originally was built as a
business intelligence and analytics tool
for analysts marketers and
product managers it has this really
awesome layer of technology
called look ml the look modeling
language
which allows you to express business
logic
and then your end users can derive
insights from the data with no code
at all so they don't need to know sql
and they don't need to run mapreduce
jobs
so it's really evolved now to become an
extensible platform
to power other applications so you can
get the richness of
every data source connected to looker
that has look ml
built on top of it you can also leverage
looker's governance and security model
as well as borrow from its front end as
well
so we're not really going to be talking
too much about liquor today there's
plenty of content out there available
we're going to be primarily focused on
looker's platform
so there's three different facets that
looker offers
the embed and the api these are ways of
getting looker
into your application and
the extension framework is really to
change looker so that ways it becomes
more
the application that you want the
embedded looker
this is the way of getting
visual elements within looker such as
dashboards or the explorers or save
reports
and you plot that right into your
application if you don't like the way
that lookers dashboards or
reports look that's what the api and sdk
are for
these are lower level building blocks
that we offer so you can build
a completely bespoke experience from
scratch and for a case study nick will
primarily be focused on
looking at the api
finally we have the extension framework
the extension framework is again
this this is to mold looker to be
whatever you want whatever suits your
data needs
uh you can use your own custom
javascript directly within looker
so let's dive into the first uh facet of
looker's platform
the embedded looker so here we have some
application code
this is on your server application it's
actually
one of lookers sdks this is our
javascript sdk
we provide our sdk in many different
languages such as
java python go whatever you would like
to use
so the first thing we need to do on our
server is to
provide which server which looker server
we're going to
request the embed from and also the
shared secret
to authenticate our application to that
looker
once we've taken care of the security
configurations
we can now define some user context for
our embed
so the user context really serves two
different purposes
first we get end-to-end tracing of that
user as they're
using our native application and looker
and secondly we're also tightly coupling
the security between the native
application
and looker we identified the user
we can either use a single sign-on
service available
if we already have that built out or we
can just use the native applications
metadata
and provide some sort of user id to the
looker this
context is also really important to
provide to look because this is what
governs what they can see in looker in
terms of data
and also which features in liquor they
have access to within that embed
now we're going to switch gears a little
bit we're going to jump into the front
end of the application
we're finally going to instantiate our
embed once the embed is instantiated
we can couple that with the native
application through the event bus
in this example we're modifying which
buttons are actually driving the
dashboard's interaction by binding
listeners in our native application
on top of looker's embed
so here's what it looks like uh we have
our native application
outside of this red outline and within
the red outline we have
embedded looker you can see this if
you're familiar with lookers dashboards
this is just the themed looker dashboard
but if you notice
there's no filters like you don't see
lookers native filters we're actually
building
filters outside within the native
application and coupling that
to the embedded dashboard
through the event bus you can imagine
how this can rapidly
accelerate your development of
applications because you're not really
building too much front end code or data
visualization code
so if you want something different
though like if our dashboards or reports
really don't meet your needs that's
really when we start recommending the
api
so here's a our api documentation page
and you can see the large list of
different methods we offer
these actually are the methods that we
use internally to build looker
itself and we offer them to you
uh to build your applications so you
have
a hundred percent coverage of what
looker can do directly through our api
here's an example of an api application
that nick has built with his team at
four mile
so if you're again if you're familiar
with looker right off the bat this looks
like a native
explorer in looker but this is actually
very different in this segment
application
we're really building the experience for
the user to be working with different
audience segments
and cohorts in mind so you're really
just comparing cohorts
and looking at the results between them
instead of building these complex filter
groups
so here we're building out one of the
cohorts using the attributes available
within our user data set and once we've
built out this cohort or multiple
cohorts
we can start doing reporting against
them to to search for
outliers or you know maybe positive or
negative performances
within a specific area of that cohort so
again if you're familiar with query
builder this is a much lighter weight
and much more
custom tailored experience designed for
marketers who are focused on cohort
research
here we have another application that
was built on top of our api this was
built for
global payments and this was a merchant
portal
and allows the merchants to see their
transactions over time
so they can see each of their given
customers
what they're making transactions on when
they made it and what kind of metadata
is associated with those transactions
we also have top level reporting to see
overall
the cash flow throughout the day
we're also going to be diving more into
the api when we cover our case study
lastly this is the newest facet to
lookers platform
which is the extension framework so the
texture framework is
very different from the embed and api
route
because you really don't have to host
anything you don't have any application
uh server yourself you don't have a back
end or a front end
looker is all of that so what you're
doing is you're
sending us your custom javascript which
will be
encapsulated so that ways your data
sources are still protected and also
your looker is protected
but you're still able to get the data
experience that you really want
so here this
extension was built by four mile and
next team again
we if you notice we are still inside
looker we have the looker menu bar at
the top
but this is a highly branded experience
we've augmented looker
with the user's native context in mind
to help them discover insights and
hopefully
increase actionability we're making
looker
feel more like home to them
in this next dashboard we're overlaying
multiple metrics
so for for this example this is a shoe a
sportswear company
and uh we're looking at how weather
is impacting the supply chain in terms
of orders and dollar
value to the business so hopefully you
can see how
the extension framework really helps you
build these experiences that
just having tables and graphs don't
necessarily
help the users in drawing insights you
want something really really custom or
unique in looker we encourage using the
extension framework
so if you're interested in learning more
about also how other people are using
looker as a platform or more about how
other people are using
each of these facets there's lots of
different resources available
first there's the liquor blocks
directory this is these are just
code examples snippets that you can
take and drop that right in your
application
we also have community libraries uh
community tools such as
linters stress testing tools and finally
just look at mel patterns
so if you have a specific type of data
set we already have like the best
ways of analyzing that data set and you
could just steal that from us
so with that i'm going to turn it over
to nick so that way we can look at a
case study
of actually building an application on
top of the looker platform
thank you so much mike um yeah so we at
four mile had the great pleasure of
partnering with mike and his team over
at looker recently
on a year-long engagement to build a
large-scale data application
on top of the looker api for a major
global retailer
and i'm super excited to be here today
with you to share a little bit about the
underlying business need that we were
trying to address
the technical approach we took and some
of the outcomes
so let's dive in our starting point on
this engagement
was an internal analytics application
that our customer had previously built
whose goal is really to serve metrics
to their retail merchants so the
merchants are the folks that
are making decisions about what to stock
on the shelves
from which vendors to purchase and how
to price each item so really
kind of foundational stuff for any
retail business
at the scale that this particular
customer of ours operates
pricing decisions you know involving
pennies either way can have
outcomes uh implications in the millions
of dollars so
all of this decision making support is
very strategic
this application had been in development
for about two years
they had had about 100 people plus
working on it
and generally the consensus was that
there was
insufficient level of engagement people
just really weren't
adopting the application and the return
on investment just wasn't there
additionally i think because of a lack
of speed and agility
they were really focusing on a
one-size-fits-all approach to their
analytics
so it was very top down the bottom line
was that the application just really
wasn't keeping pace with the analytic
needs of this organization
and without access to timely and
relevant insights
merchants were just not really using
data to drive their decision making
so our mandate if you will was to come
in and
just highly accelerate the delivery of
the right insights
to the right people at the right time
and ultimately to help
drive the fundamentals of this business
through data
broadly speaking i think any bi
application will be composed of a couple
of different layers
on one hand you'll have a data back end
typically consisting of some kind of
storage
and a query engine sitting on top of
that and then you'll have
application code which serves to
provide a user interface and allow data
exploration and
data visualizations we really saw
opportunities in both of these layers to
drive
further acceleration on the
data back-end side our customer was
using thoughtspot along with a very
manual and time-consuming data
engineering workflow
and as a result you know when a product
person wanted to publish a new insight
it would take
weeks and sometimes months to get that
in front of users to even find out if it
had any kind of business value
so iteration cycles were just taking way
too long
wilker talks about this problem uh as
the
the data breadlines problem in which you
know you stand in a queue for a long
time and
you wait to get your little nugget of of
wisdom and then
having you know gotten a little taste
for it you don't have to get back in the
back of the queue and wait all over
again
the real wonder of data analytics in my
opinion is that
good answers beget new questions and
if your goal really is to build a data
driven organization and culture
your data stack needs to be responsive
to this virtuous cycle of
inquiry liquid's really
built to solve this exact problem it's
kind of its core value proposition
and by adding looker to the stack now
new questions can be answered
without this big long round trip of
moving and transforming data
but rather with just simple changes to
looker's data model via
locoml which mike referred to earlier
and
those changes can be done practically in
real time and by
people with much less technical
sophistication
so just by applying looker to the stack
we brought a huge increase in speed and
flexibility
on the application code side we
replaced a lot of verbose and poorly
encapsulated code with an application
development toolkit
that we built which gives engineers the
means to deliver
new data insights just an order of
magnitude more quickly and with a lot
less complexity
the toolkit offers a high level of
reusability
and a very clear separation of concerns
so
if you'll permit let's dive in one layer
deeper and just take a closer look at
the toolkit
it's kind of composed of two levels
there's a data service kind of a
back-end data service which
is responsible for proxying
api requests to looker and then
on the front end sdk side there is some
capabilities to
build data visualizations in a more
kind of recurring way so we'll take a
look at each of those two
in turn the architecture of
the application is composed of a series
of micro services each
really in charge of their own area of
concern so there's one that does
authentication there's another
that does logging and there is also one
of course that surfaces
thought spot-backed data to power
front-end visualizations
we elected to integrate into this
existing architecture by building a
parallel
looker-backed data service this had the
huge advantage of not really requiring
us to rip and replace
any part of the existing architecture if
we had done so it probably would have
brought
product development to a standstill and
probably would have been met with a lot
of
resistance let's say resistance to
change so instead we just built this
parallel service
and without a lot of fuss we just
started doing it a better
and faster way and let the results speak
for themselves
in a pretty short amount of time
engineering teams fairly organically
just started moving
over to using the looker data back
service
because it just made their jobs easier
and allowed them to do a lot more with a
lot less
the other really good advantage about
this kind of data as a sidecar service
is that it exists somewhat decoupled
from the application context in which
it was developed which means it can be
reused in a whole variety of different
ways
we've essentially built a capability as
much as we've built a specific solution
and the capability can be used to for
example power other internal
applications or
even externally facing applications that
our customer might want to monetize
given the constraints of this particular
enterprise environment
our data service wasn't built in the
cloud but
it's important to note that in other
circumstances you could use
cloud-based api type services like
apigee for example
to play the same role in this kind of
architecture
okay so with that discussion of the data
service let's pivot a little bit
and talk about um the development
toolkit
that we built that handles the front end
visualizations
for the front end sdk we built a series
of reusable react components
each one representing a different data
visualization type
we developed the interface you're
looking at here which exposes each of
the different vis components
and acts kind of like live documentation
allowing developers
and product owners and ux designers to
collaborate on the best way
to tell the given data story anyone with
access can adjust the vis configuration
parameters
to get the vis just right prior to
committing any code
we then connected these components to
the look or data service we just spoke
about
and parameterized them such that we can
pass the id
of any pre-built looker query object
connect it to the viz and essentially
render the results here in real time
once everybody's happy with the results
it's just a matter really of copying a
couple of lines of generated code
into the react application code base
so by way of both the looker data
service we spoke about earlier
and this front-end sdk we've been able
to
leverage existing capabilities within
looker
and build a scalable architecture that
vastly accelerates time to value for our
customers
while also decreasing complexity the net
result on this engagement
has been a 10x increase in the speed it
takes to publish new insights in the
application
and all of that with about a third of
the engineering resources required
so now with relevant and timely insights
at their disposal
these retail merchants are using the
application in much higher numbers
and with much more regularity than ever
before
so from a purely quantitative
perspective
i think it's fair to say achievement
unlocked but
honestly the qualitative outcomes of
this engagement to me are
even more exciting what we delivered
initially was a series of capabilities
offering speed and flexibility for the
product team and the engineering team
but subsequently we've taken these same
capabilities and
offered them to end users allowing them
really for the first time to
self-service insights
and as a result the product has moved
from this very
top-down one-size-fits-all approach to
analytics
to one that really promotes much greater
data democratization and ultimately
better decision making throughout the
business the net result is an
organization
much better prepared to steer the course
through challenging economic
environments so that pretty much wraps
up what i want to share about this
engagement
i do want to encourage you to explore
how looker's platform capabilities
can transform your own data culture and
in turn your business
with that i'm going to go ahead and hand
it back to mike
all right thank you nick for that uh
walkthrough of the case study
so i really hope this talk gives you
guys a good sense of
the looker platform's capabilities how
it works and what it can offer you
hopefully you're imagining how it can
enable you and your team to build some
really cool new data experiences
developing with the right tools can
really decrease the complexity
and also maintenance costs of our rich
applications
and this helps us rapidly build more and
more powerful applications as well
it's important really to note that
looker is really just
a piece of the tool set within google's
development
environment in google's ecosystem
there are lots of other tools designed
with developers and their applications
in mind
together with by using all of these
tools correctly you can really
accelerate development
and enable your ability to deliver some
custom experiences
again because we're freeing up resources
or augmenting our resources
this new capacity allows us to really
innovate
and make groundbreaking business
discoveries for our end users
if you're interested in learning more
here are some links uh to the looker
platform
and of course also to 4mile so you can
see what nick and his team
are up to and their projects
with that thanks so much for coming to
our talk everyone
thank you everybody